(cris de la foule)
- Les Chiliens ont le choix
entre "j'approuve"
ou "je rejette" le projet
de nouvelle constitution.
Les partisans des deux camps
ont dû mettre un terme
à leur campagne 48 heures
avant le vote de dimanche.
(sirène)
À la suite des violentes
manifestations de 2019,
les Chiliens ont voté à 78 %
en faveur d'une nouvelle
constitution. Quel que soit
le résultat, ce référendum
est historique.
PEDRO REYES GARCIA, journaliste
- C'est très, très important,
parce que c'est la façon,
disons, que l'on a trouvée,
on peut dire, pour terminer
avec la transition.
Je pense qu'il y a un accord.
La transition démocratique
après la dictature de nonochet
qui s'est terminée en 1990.
- Une convention élue a rédigé
un projet qui compte près
de 400 articles et un vaste
programme, trop vae,e,
peut-être, et trop audacieux
pour une société en grande
partie conservatrice.
Les partisans du "oui"
apprécie l le catalogue
de droits sociaux du projet en
matière de santé, d'éducation,
droits civiques, à l'avortement,
respect des minorités
et des différences.
(coup de sifflet)
Les opposants rejettent
les réfoeses des systèmes
politique et judiciaire qui
affaibliraient l'indépendance
des institutions. Surtout,
ils sont contre la notion
delulurinationalité,
qui reconnaîtrait les peuples
autochtones en tant que nations
dans la nation. Cela vise
la communauté Mapuche du sud
du Chili, qui compte pour 13 %
de la population et revendique,
non sans violence parfois,
ses territoires ancestraux.
Le pays est profondément
divisé, mais les sondages
penchent pour l'instant vers
le rejet. Exceptionnellement,
le vote est obligatoire,
ce qui rend les prévisions
moins certaines, car sur
les 15 millions d'électeurs,
une bonne partie d'entre eux
se seraient abstenus.
(applaudissements)
Le président Gabriel Boric
s'est fait élire en promettant
de faire adopter la nouvelle
constitution, qu'il a fait
imprimer à 900 000 exemplaires
pour que les gens votent, selon
lui, en connaissance de cause.
Un pari risqué pour ce jeune
président devenu assez
impopulaire.
- Mais, ça a été justement ça
les problèmes du gouvernement,
parce qu'il a uni, disons,
son gouvernement à approuver
la constitution. Alors, si...
la constitution, la proposition
est rejetée, ça veut dire
que ça va être en lien
avec l'évaluation de
son gouvernement aussi.
- En cas de rejet, on craint
un retour de manifestations
dans un pays polarisé, tendu,
qui redoute de plus en plus
la violence et l'iécécurité.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Montréa